[Musique]
ce troupeau de chèvres afin long voyage
avant d'arriver ici
cinq mille kilomètres dans les montagnes
de l'oural russe en banlieue de la ville
de yekaterinburg la chèvre d'un animal
exotique
qu'à cela ne tienne cette ferme qui
appartient à un rôle digne métallurgique
a décidé de se lancer dans une
expérience unique
faire venir un millier de chèvre des
alpes françaises
coût 1 millions d'euros le but commencer
une production de fromage à grande
échelle au poignet je te pose de dougie
le plus difficile c'est de comprendre
que la chèvre est un animal complètement
différent elles ne sont pas comme les
vaches elles ont besoin de soins
différents
elles sont plus sociable la directrice
de la production laitière chéu gmk agro
est persuadé sans les spécialistes
français qui les ont conseillés
cette aventure aurait été impossible
nourriture soins même la technologie de
traite bien particulière ils ont tout
appris de leurs collègues de france
même leur nom de marque et français
aujourd'hui les chèvres alpines de
l'oural donne plus de deux tonnes de
lait par jour presque la totalité
destinés à la production du coeur d'une
à notre entreprise peut produire jusqu'à
6,5 kg de fromage par jour
c'est beaucoup pour une seule région
c'est pourquoi nous sommes intéressés à
des grands marchés comme moscou saint
pétersbourg anckière votre machine il y
a encore trois ou quatre à l'est seul
fromage de chèvre qu'on pouvait trouver
dans les épiceries russes étaient
importés de france l'industrie du
fromage russe se résumait à quelques
fromages à pâte dure
rien de très raffinée tout le reste
c'était de l'importation
mais après l'annexion de la crimée et
l'imposition des sanctions occidentales
moscou a décidé de riposter et a
interdit l'importation de centaines de
produits les tablettes des épiceries se
sont littéralement vidés ya ces bolides
prose aussi scoré c'est cependant ce qui
concerne l'industrie du fromage oui les
sanctions ont favorisé son développement
c'est devenu une niche intéressante pour
les entreprises russes ou six parce que
le gouvernement s'est mis à donner des
subventions
et il a fallu beaucoup d'argent à son
entreprise car elle partait de zéro
le troupeau de chèvres a coûté cher mais
aussi la technologie de production de
fromage les équipements la formation des
employés
aujourd'hui j'aime cadre au produit
quatre fromages différents de la bûche
au crottin en passant par le camembert
il ya de magique au maire pour lui je
crois que nous sommes maintenant assez
bons pour pouvoir aller à une exposition
à peine
c'est ce qu'on vise dans l'avenir sans
complexe six mois après avoir produit
son premier fromage de chèvre avis
l'entreprise rêve déjà de concurrencer
les produits français mondialement
reconnu cet excès de confiance et l
image de l'extraordinaire essor du
secteur agricole
en russie vladimir poutine a fait de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire de la
russie une ambition personnelle
une des rares sorties de sa campagne
électorale au printemps dernier il l'a
fait ici dans une ferme expérimentale à
krasnodar près de la mer noire où nous
l'avons suivi selon certains
observateurs les contres sanctions qu'il
a imposées en 2014 bannissant les
importations des produits alimentaires
de l'union européenne avait un bus
secret favoriser la production nationale
l'affaiblissement du rouble est dedans
cette stratégie a été gagnante sur toute
l'année
la concurrence était énorme les produits
agricoles de l'union européenne est
arrivée ici dans des quantités
illimitées et nous avions de la
difficulté à vendre notre production
plus maintenant nous vendons notre
production sur notre marché
cet agriculteur de la région de la mer
baltique comme pratiquement tous ceux
qui se sont rendus à la conférence sur
le développement agricole présidé par
nul autre que
murs poutine ne tarit pas d'éloges au
sujet du président aujourd'hui la russie
est devenue le plus grand exportateur de
céréales au monde alors que jusqu'à tout
récemment elle en importait les
exportations de légumes de serre
augmentent de 30 % par année
les produits alimentaires on remplace l
armement au deuxième rang des
exportations
tout juste après le pétrole et le gaz
pas banal pour le pays inventeur de la
kalachnikov
la russie va bientôt devenir un leader
mondial en agriculture
ces petits producteurs de fromage ne
tarit pas d'éloges au sujet du baume
agricole russe réserve chez nous la
croissance des petites fermes et de
l'ordre de 40 % ces cinq dernières
années
c'est une révolution avant que vladimir
poutine arrive on mourait pratiquement
de faim depuis qu'il est là on est
devenu des exportateurs dans l'oral avec
l'arrivée des chèvres la révolution
risque de se faire sentir encore plus
j'aime kahn n'a pas seulement
l'intention de produire des fromages on
se lance maintenant dans l'élevage et la
vente de chèvres à grande échelle pour
promouvoir la production de produits
caprins dans la région et au-delà
qui sait la russie pourrait même devenir
un exportateur de fromage de chèvre il y
en a qui en rêve déjà
on va faire pour le canada un produit
spécial semi dur qui se transporte nous
vouloir déjà exporté au canada ça peut
paraître prétentieux mais les
producteurs de l'oural voit encore plus
grand
d'ici trois ans il compte devenir la
plus grande ferme de chèvre de toute
l'europe avec vingt mille têtes et 18
mille tonnes de lait par année
qui dit mieux
[Musique]